>>> SOME PEOPLE FEEL LIKE, OKAY,
WHY SHOULD I TRUST SCIENCE.
DOES THAT MEAN I'M NOT TRUSTING
GOD?
I THINK GOD WORKS THROUGH
SCIENCE IN CASES LIKE THIS AND
WE OUGHT TO CELEBRATE THAT AND
GIVE THANKS TO GOD'S GRACE AT
THIS KIND OF THING IS POSSIBLE.
>> IS THAT DR. FRANCIS COLLINS
OF THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH TALKING ABOUT ONE OF THE
GROUPS OF AMERICANS WHO ARE MOST
SKEPTICAL OF GETTING THE
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE THAT'S WHITE
EVANGELICALS.
THERE'S ABOUT 41 MILLION
ACCORDING TO THE PEW RESEARCH
CENTER AND MOST SAY THEY WON'T
GET THE SHOT.
EXPERTS SAY WHAT SOME
EVANGELICAL PASTORS PREACH FROM
THE PULPIT FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
HAD A PROFOUND EFFECT IN SHAPING
THEIR OPINIONS.
>> DO NOT TAKE THE VACCINE.
[ SPEAKING IN A FOREIGN
LANGUAGE ]
>> BELIEVE IN THE BLOOD MUCH
JESUS.
BELIEVE IN DIVINE IMMUNITY.
>> THAT IS PASTOR WHOSE CHURCH
IN MIAMI HAS BEEN A MUST VISIT
FOR REPUBLICANS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE IN RECENT YEARS INCLUDING
FORMER FLORIDA GOVERNOR AND
CURRENT U.S. SENATOR RICK SCOTT
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO LAUNCHED
HIS EVANGELICAL SUPPORT GROUP
THERE AND INACTIVITIED THE
PASTOR TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
IN MIAMI-DADE COUNTY WHERE HE IS
HEADQUARTERED MORE THAN 6,000
PEOPLE HAVE DIED FROM COVID.
LAST YEAR WHILE THE CDC
RECOMMENDED LIMITING MASK
GATHERINGS, HE SAID THE FEAR
THAT KEPT PEOPLE HOME WAS A
DEMONIC SPIRIT AND HE ALSO SAID
THIS.
>> I CAN'T GO TO CHURCH TODAY.
WHY?
I THINK THE PASTOR WILL HAVE A
VIRUS.
IF WE DIE, WE DIE FOR CHRIST.
>> HE'S JUST ONE OF A NUMBER OF
EVANGELICAL PREACHERS WHO HAVE
SPREAD DISINFORMATION ABOUT OR
DOWN PLAYED THE CORONAVIRUS.
>> THAT'S CALLED GERMOPHOBIC.
YOU THINK I'M SUCKING THE VIRUS
OFF OF HER?
>> I CAME TODAY TO DECLARE
VICTORY OVER THE VIRUS.
>> COVID-19.
>> I BLOW THE WIND OF GOD ON
YOU.
YOU ARE DESTROYED FOREVER.
>> YOU ARE DESTROYED FOREVER.
>> AND YOU'LL NEVER BE BACK.
>> THAT LAST ONE WAS TEXAS MEGA
CHURCH PASTOR KENNETH COPELAND
WHEN AT THE TIME THE U.S. DEATH
TOLL HIT 10 HOUSE TO.
MORE THAN A YEAR LATER 570,000
HAVE DIED IN THE U.S..
MORE THAN 31 MILLION OTHERS HAVE
BEENAND YOU WILL NEVER BE BACK.
>> THAT LAST ONE WAS TEXAS MEGA
CHURCH PASTOR KENNETH COPELAND
WHEN
HE ALSO SAID CHRISTIANS ABOUT
IMMUNE FROM THE VIRUS BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP RECOVERED FROM
IT.
>> THIS DISPLAY OF OUR
GOVERNMENT GIVING GOD THANKS,
FOR HELPING HIM IN THAT TIME.
AND HE WALKED OUT IMMUNE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> SOMEHOW.
GLORY TO GOD.
WOO!
THANK YOU JESUS.
>> YEAH, AMEN.
>> COME ON, MAN.
SOME -- HEY, WE'RE IMMUNE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS
THING WITH A HOLY SPIRIT
IMMUNITY FROM THE WORKS OF THE
DEVIL.
>> AT LEAST HE ACKNOWLEDGED
THERE IS A PANDEMIC.
>> THERE IS NO PANDEMIC.
>> THAT IS JOHN MacARTHUR, MEGA
CHURCH PASTOR IN L.A. WHO TOLD
HIS PASTORS LAST AUGUST WHILE
HOLDING INDOOR SERVICES DEFYING
THE STATE'S HEALTH GUIDANCE AS
CONGREGANTS GATHERED, SHOOK
HANDS AND SANG MANY DID SO
WITHOUT MASKS EVEN THOUGH WE
LEARNED EARLY ON THAT CHURCHES
WERE SUPER SPREADERS AFTER A
CHURCH IN THE STATE HAD 5 PEOPLE
FALLING ILL AND TWO DYING.
MacARTHUR THEN SANG A DIFFERENT
TUNE.
>> THIS IS NOT PERSECUTION OF
THE CHURCH.
THIS IS GOVERNMENT LAW FOR THE
GREATER GOOD OF THE POPULATION.
IT'S NOT NOBLE TO SAY, WELL,
WE'RE GOING TO MEET WHATEVER THE
GOVERNMENT SAYS.
THAT IS THE KIND OF DEFIANCE
THAT MAKES CHRISTIANITY LOOK
ANYTHING BUT LOVING.
>> WE CONTACTED MacARTHUR AND
HIS CHURCH ABOUT THIS SHIFT IN
TONE.
AND WE RECEIVED AN EMAIL BACK
FROM JENNA ELLIS FORMER TRUMP
SENIOR LEGAL ADVISER WHO SAID
SHE REPRESENTED THE PASTOR AND
THE CHURCH ASKED IF THEY STAND
BY THE COMMENT, QUOTE, THERE IS
NO PANDEMIC" ELLIS DID NOT
RESPOND.
SHE CONTRACTED THE VIRUS HERSELF
LAST DECEMBER.
IT IS FED BY A MIXTURE OF
DISTRUST IN GOVERNMENT,
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW VACCINES
WORK.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA ONE CONSPIRACY
THEORY THAT SOME EADVANTAGE
GELCALS SEIZE ON IS THAT THE
VACCINE IS THE MARK OF THE
BEAST.
IT IS A REFERENCE TO THE BACK OF
REVELATIONS.
ANOTHER BASELESS CLAIM IS THAT
THE VACCINE IS ACTUALLY A REDUCE
FOR IMPLANTING MICROCHIPS IN
AMERICANS.
AND RECENTLY JIM BAKKER USED
HESS PLATFORM TO HOST WALKING
DEAD CONSPIRACY THEORIES
SERIOUSLY WHEN ONE OF HIS GUESTS
TOLD THE AUDIENCE COVID-19 NASAL
TESTED ARE MEANT THE STEAL DNA
THE TURN AMERICANS INTO
FLESH-EATING ZOMBIES.
>> ZOMBIES THAT ARE ON EARTH ARE
DISEASE LIKE ANY OTHER DISEASE
THAT AFFECTS PEOPLE AND THEY
BECOME LIKE ZOMBIES; IS THAT
RIGHT.
>> ZOMBIES ALSO HAVE THE EVIL
ENTITY KNOWN AS DEMON
POSSESSION.
>> BAKER ALSO PUSHED A PRODUCT
ON HIS SHOW LAST YEAR CALLED
SILVER SOLUTION THAT HE FALSELY
SAID COULD RID COVID FROM YOUR
BODY.
IT CONTAINS A SUBSTANCE THAT CAN
BE DANGEROUS TO YOUR HEALTH.
>> THIS INFLUENZA THAT IS NOW
CIRCLING THE GLOBE, YOU ARE
SAYING THAT SILVER SOLUTION
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE?
>> LET'S SAY IT HASN'T BEEN
TESTED ON THIS STRAIN OF THE
CORONAVIRUS, BUT IT HAS BEEN
TESTED ON OTHER STRAINS.
>> YEAH.
>> OF THE CORONAVIRUS, AND HAS
BEEN ABLE TO ELIMINATE IT WITHIN
12 HOURS.
>> MEANT OF THE COMMENTS WE JUST
PLAYED CAME DURING THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE VIRUS BUT JUST LAST
WEEK CNN WENT TO BATON ROUGE AND
MET WITH A PASTOR TONE SPELLS.
SPELLS ADAMANTLY IS AGAINST
GETTING A VACCINE.
>> ANTI-VAXX, AND ANTI-VACCINE,
ANTI-GOVERNMENT, AND I AM PROUD
TO BE ANTI-GOVERNMENT.
>> LISTENING TO ALL OF THIS
DISINFORMATION IT MIGHT SURPRISE
YOU TO LEARN THAT SOME OF THE
BIGGEST EVANGELICAL VOICE THIS
IS THE COUNTRY MADE A CRUSADE OF
PROMOTING THE VACCINE LIKE THIS
PROMINENT SOUTHERN BAPTIST
PREACHER.
>> I AM CALLING THESE VACCINES
AN EARLY CHRISTMAS PRESENT FROM
GOD.
IT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE US THAT
GOD WOULD USE SCIENCE TO BRING
HEALING INTO OUR WORLD.
AFTER ALL IN THE PAST PEOPLE
LIKE ISAAC NOW TON AND PASCHALL,
AND LOUIS PASTURE WERE NOT JUST
MEN OF SCIENCE BUT MEN OF FAITH
WHO BELIEVED GOD CREATED THIS
WORLD IN AN ORDERLY WAY THAT
COULD BE STUDIED AND BENEFITTED
FROM.
>> AND GRONK LISTEN GRAHAM WROTE
ON FACEBOOK TO HIS NEARLY 10
MILLION FOLLOWERS THAT JESUS
WOULD ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE USING
THE VACCINE TO SAVE LIVES.
BASE ON THE PARABLE OF THE GOOD
SAMARITAN IN THE BIBLE HE SAID I
WOULD SAY YES, I THINK VACCINES
AND MEDICINES TREAT SUFFERING
AND SAVE LIVES.
THERE ARE 20,000 COMMENTS ON
GRAHAM'S POST CHOCK FULL OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
MISINFORMATION ALONG WITH THESE
TYPES OF MESSAGES LIKE SATANIC
SELLOUT AND YOU, MY FRIEND
FRANKLIN, GRAHAM, ARE LEADING
YOUR SHEEP TO SLAUGHTER.
AND FATHER I PRAY YOU WOULD OPEN
MR. GRAHAM'S EYES AND STOP HIM
FROM LEADING OTHERS ASTRAY.
THE LOSS THIS COUNTRY HAS
EXPERIENCE OVER THE PAST YEAR
HAS BEEN OVERWHELMING AND MANY
AMERICANS TURNED TO FAMILY,
FRIENDS, AND TOPHYTE FOR COMFORT
AND ANSWERS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR MA